let's do speed rounds so here's what i
want to do this is the last thing and
then we'll wrap up we're coming to the
end of it here is i'll give you a name
give me one word that comes to your mind
okay andrew cuomo
andrew cuomo the former governor
he did it because if he didn't do it he
wouldn't quit okay mark vargas
i love mark vargas mark vargas was the
mystery man who helped me come out of
prison
trump
i love trump i love trump i got to know
him on celebrity apprentice
really liked him people don't realize
he's a real kind man when you know him i
saw him do things off camera that were
very kind he was very kind of my little
girls during a very difficult time
i love trump and by the way what he did
for me benefited him politically not at
all he didn't have to do that he gets no
benefit but he did it he saw something
wrong it ended it a lot of people in
politics politics are not like that
trump's very different obama
very disappointed obama um
i'll answer that by saying one of my
colleagues in prison after obama didn't
cut me loose
um asked me what about your friend garf
god what about your friend obama he
didn't give you a clemency my answer was
i'm never voting for that guy again
desantis
up-and-coming leader in the republican
party
um
he won't be trump trump would be him if
he runs he won't run trump's the big dog
right now in the republican party he
won't run he will not run against
interesting vic mill
my father-in-law who's been very good to
me in many ways very bad to me in many
ways
i love him
i do he's my father-in-law he's got a
lot of good qualities
um he's 83 years old and i marvel at how
well he's doing at 83 and i'm very happy
about that
yeah rahm emanuel
i always like rahm and banjo he's a
tough guy he's a doer
he's a member of the fellowship of the
tours that you talked about that teddy
roosevelt talked about
he's ruthless though very ruthless and
uh
the means justify the ends as far as
that guy is concerned
steven schwartzman writes in his book
you know who steven schwartzman is i
don't i mean he's a billionaire and he
says you know one time you know i got
invited to a meeting with rahm emanuel
and obama and he said we had the biggest
shouting match cursing at each other he
says i realized how strong rahm emanuel
was but i knew i had to learn how to
negotiate with this guy because he's not
going away he's on he's on obama's
something in that emanuel family blood
his brother's like the biggest agent in
hollywood and there's another brother
who's like a physicist or something
no there's three of them as i understand
it there's the agent hollywood agent
there's rom and there's the ethicist and
i refer to the ethicist as the black
sheep of the family
how about anderson cooper
he wasn't nice to me when i came home
and uh so that was disappointing so uh
low marks for him okay bob menendez i
knew bob menendez when we were in
congress together and bob menendez
had had the law been applied to me my
case the way it was applied to menendez
my case would have been thrown out just
like his his case was the judge threw it
out for insufficient evidence i should
have got the same treatment george ryan
george ryan is an old school illinois
politician he was a republican but
pretty much like democrat machine type
values
he's an old man he's lost his wife
he did his time
i don't think that i don't think that
he was innocent
fitzgerald patrick evil wicked
a man who has abused his power
to frame people
evil and wicked and i think he's done it
to a lot of black people too
interesting mike madigan
um
mike madigan all about politics and
himself
what
as cynical as they come politically
great skill hard worker very smart very
disciplined i think a good dad
um but he squandered an opportunity to
do a lot of good for people because it
was all about his power and he's hurt
illinois we're the highest tax state in
the nation
because of him little caesar madigan but
he's gone now the berlin wall has
finally fallen
and maybe if there's a new day in
illinois though with this pritzker as
governor it's not
it's not it's not okay so does future
look bright for illinois
as of today no is there hope in this
coming election yes
prediction for presidency in 2024 who
becomes a president donald trump you
think so very much so really yes what's
your level of certainty
percent sixty-eight percent sixty-five
percent
what a number what do you think biden
runs again
i don't think so what do you think i
don't i don't think he'll be there and i
don't think kamala will be there no no i
don't think buying runs again i think
trump wins
there's a historical precedent to this
in 1824
a strong leader like trump andrew
jackson ran for president
and the election was thrown into the
house of representatives close there
were four people in that race
jackson was the people's choice really
and it's the same kind of constituency
trump has working people who felt
disgruntled by the elitists and the
ruling class
it was stolen from at the capitol
because henry clay the guy that ran
forth made a political deal supporting
the son of the second president john
quincy adams was the son of john adams
in exchange for that he became the
secretary of state it was called corrupt
bargain
and that's what it was known four years
later all those jacksonians were
energized and ready to go and he came
back and won overwhelmingly
i think it's going to rip history he's
going to repeat itself with trump couple
more names for if we have time it's
being that year the former governor of
illinois chicago comes to mind michael
jordan
i had dinner with michael jordan once
when i was governor he's fantastic of
course we love michael jordan i mean
michael jordan elvis muhammad ali you
can't get any better than that scotty
pippen
not so much
did you ever have the opportunity to
hang out with dennis rodman
no but you know dennis rodman and i have
one thing in common you know what it is
both got fired from the apprentice well
said we both got fired by donald trump
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]